are you are there people from your life
that are like
[ __ ] like they looked at you or wrote
you off and now you're like kind of
yeah are there people like jesus christ
are there kids that their parents were
like don't hang out with with
zan and now yeah oh yeah that had right
yeah still
probably some of them yeah well they're
still like that's how to say yeah
yeah yeah like you mean it um yeah it's
definitely people that wrote me off
pretty early on and
uh but you know once you get a little
bit of fame a little bit of money it's
like they all come back but
there's still pretty good amount of them
that are still like oh [ __ ] this kid
right
right because like if you come from like
a small town like i did you don't want
to see nobody
do well right it's kind of [ __ ] up but
it's like
i don't know people hate on like that
type of success yeah i mean i
i think you did it too in a way that
like you know
a lot of people are probably like you
dropped out of school you started your
music like
that's the story of a lot of people a
lot of people don't succeed like that
yeah if you it's if you don't want to go
the more conventional route
as long as you know chase what you want
like maybe a dream or you know like uh
steve jobs he dropped out i think bill
gates dropped out
yeah right yes i think of you steve jobs
and bill gates in the same sense
i usually i i usually group you guys
together bill gates
three people that took an alternative
route when did the tats
when did you struggle a while with the
tats oh 18 i got my mom's name candy
tatted on my
amazing and there was no type of success
because now they're pretty common to
face tattoos but back then yeah back
then there was nobody uh back then
it was just a very select amount of
people that were making soundcloud rap
you know little pete
xxx me and it wasn't like trendy yet and
but i saw it and i was like oh that's
it looks cool i thought it looked cool
this looks cool yeah yeah and then i
uh i was like what can i get that my my
parents aren't gonna freak out
i'll just get my mom's name oh yeah yeah
yeah that was the first one
yeah it was candy and people they
thought i got it because like eye candy
and i was like no i didn't even think of
that yeah it's kind of good though yeah
um
but i got it so she wouldn't be that mad
she's still really [ __ ] pissed
yeah i was about to say yeah i guarantee
she was still very
she's so pissed and she's like well now
you have to do something
crazy it almost put you in that box it
did you had the [ __ ]
you had to pop some other something it's
hard to walk into a job interview with
the candy on your cheeks yeah they're
going to be like and have a guy go yeah
let's get him involved yeah he should be
the regional manager yeah he should be
the regional medic
is it is it wild now when you look back
at that kid
who wanted to be a photographer and
you're like like that kid was just had
no idea what was about to happen
no no [ __ ] idea was about to happen
because
like i said i i did music because i
thought it was cool all my friends did
music and then it actually started
working out i was like oh man
this is crazy like this actually happens
like nobody
talks about that like this actually can
happen you know people always think
about dreams and stuff and it's just so
far fed it's a dream
yeah you know but for many people it is
far-fetched i mean
you're talented i mean you freaking
appreciate it thank you and i i
i appreciate how inspirational you are
oh thank you man that's not what i do
but the i tell everyone take that dream
and shut now
um because i know a lot of people who
are just they're not i mean they have
their literal dreams where they're
waking up and not
asking you for money or asking you know
their parents
but they're they're they you have a
[ __ ] talent you're good you work
you write [ __ ] i mean that's a different
story
it it's it it be it just becomes yeah it
is work nice
but it just becomes so it just becomes
easier and easier as you get
i guess yeah you're getting better at it
right um but i just i never think about
it like that
are there people you don't keep in your
life now because you're like these are
people who are
not you know good for me they're not
good you know in terms of drugs or in
terms of partying like oh definitely
there there a lot of hangers on and
stuff oh when it when it first started
off
it it was crazy everybody wanted to to
come back in my life or
even family like a lot of family members
like uh outer family members like not my
mom or dad
right and it was just like yeah like all
the creatures
i keep them away with a stick yeah right
my family all the all the people that
used to go to christmas parties uh
with they're like oh yo diego yeah come
over and i'm like man i was a black
sheep of the family
right even like before everything so i
was like oh you guys are [ __ ]
[ __ ]
right like now that because i came up
like really poor and stuff so it was
like
so you that's what i want to ask you
about too you grew up
in in uh in redlands california which is
like
uh is is it's not riverside what it's
like uh
right next to riverside right next to
san bernardino and and you grew up you
would you were
poor you didn't have growing up i was i
was dude i was all right but then we hit
a time you know
we had a time yeah just hit the [ __ ]
everybody's hitting the time yeah yeah
and what was that like
that was horrible i was uh my grandma
had had just passed and
and uh she was like 99 so she was
[ __ ] old and
and then we were you we were relying on
that's great that 99 that's like a
mexican legend
right 99 it's crazy she was trying to
hit 100 but uh movie coco was about her
right what is that and uh but we were
what's that thing when uh
uh when you caretaker caretaker checks
you're relying on that to pay the rent
and when she passed away unfortunately
you know we couldn't get those checks
anymore
yeah recipes crime i love you all right
and then uh
we had to we were living in motels like
yeah it got that bad like
uh super eights and stuff yeah yeah man
going back and you know it's in cali
still
yeah and cali like you kaipa right above
and yeah that's [ __ ]
how old were you at that point i
probably had just turned like 18 around
19.
so you're living in like uh you know in
a one-bedroom with your
oh yeah yeah it was so in cockroaches
cognition fest it was terrible
and that [ __ ] can get pretty expensive
too of course you pay weekly
it's it's it's expensive to be poor in
america a lot of people don't realize
that it's a lot of money man
to not have credit or to not have a lot
of money and then you're in and out of
these hotels and it's
[ __ ] it got really bad and but one
thing your brothers or sisters are just
you
oh just me um well no not just me i have
a half sister and a half brother okay
um i see my sister occasionally but my
brother is actually in prison
oh wow for attempted murder okay yeah
but he gets out next year
hey he can try it again and hopefully
this time
i was like listen attack you can attempt
it you get right out you don't get it
right the first
you get right back on the on the horse
that's what i say
yeah now
ken it was he just mixed up in some bad
stuff right oh yeah he's a great
great person just makes the drugs and
yeah he's i'd like to believe he's
changed now so
yeah but you know that you never know
when you get it is he did was he in jail
when you were blown up
yeah oh my god he that's amazing
watching your little brother
right become a [ __ ] star yeah he
probably pissed him off too because he's
like in there and he's like oh [ __ ] i
want to be out there visit him uh i
haven't
he's so far away i haven't seen him in a
long time but uh next year actually yeah
when he gets out like
i got a good situation from him yeah and
when you so you're living in your kaipa
and and and you're in and out of these
motels and stuff
are you are you getting depressed are
you getting like [ __ ] [ __ ] my life
sucks and i don't know what to do
crazy because i wasn't too much
depressed about the situation i was in
at the time
but uh i was i was really just trying to
chase my dream at that i knew that
somebody in the family had to do
something to change the situation
yeah and but i you know i was just i
didn't know it was gonna happen
so at that time i did have my camera and
i was going out to shows that's how i
met all these guys i've known them for
the whole
majority of my career and i was just
taking p i was like a super fan
yeah like of these guys and they just
gave me the opportunity
to fly one day out to austin texas and
that's where i got the name lil xan
and uh just yeah it worked out it's
crazy